Bụt tưởng phạm miếng chính vừa ki công định số 1.5 sấu, ngày 20.7 năm,
hành hình khu trong 20.5 về việc hình chương khác phục hậu quả máo số 1 và 1 lúc.
Bảo cao nhé ngon của 1 năm nghiệp và 1 trường cho biết bảo đã làm 1 người chết,
1 người bà người mất tích, tả 1 người mất liên là 3 người bị thương.
Như nhà cửa, cơ sở xa sất bị thi thải.
Tụ tưởng người lời chia 1 sâu sắc tới ra điện có người bình ả,
yêu cầu các địa phương tham hoàn, khổ chợt, chứ chỉ mến phi trong người bị thương,
khẩn chương tình kiếm kêu nạn khóa phục sào thông, định nước, vén thông, ít tế, giáo dục.
Các bộ quốc phòng công an vì động lực lượng hỗ trợ.
Phó thủ tưởng trên thông hai được sào tế tục chỉ đạo.
Các địa phương phải bảo cao kết quả khá phục chức mấy làm dự hàng ngày.